j'ai vu soit la liste eh ben pour nous
c'est la catastrophe
samba c'est celle de notre première
réaction les verts jamais
stéphanie clément et son conjoint
attendait nike aiwa kim depuis trois ans
ils angoissent pendant cinq jours avant
d'apprendre que les enfants sont en vie
on était très très très heureux très
soulagé mais en même temps très très
très inquiet parce qu'on se demande où
ci a pas de denrées alimentaires s'ils
sont en danger si des épidémies sait
déjà qui pays
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent a relevé le dr
chicoine est allé à port-au-prince
chercher une centaine d'enfants haïtiens
qu'il a ensuite suivi pendant quelques
mois ou quelques années avec la femme
malade juste maintenant avait il y avait
qui avait une coupure un autre qui était
plus trop baptisé que l'autre mais
globalement ça s'est bien passé on a pas
eu d urgence énorme
sinon les trucs habituels haïti c'est la
diaries et des pneumonies le canada
adopte des mesures extraordinaires pour
faire venir les enfants qui étaient déjà
avant le séisme
jumelés à des parents adoptants 203
petits haïtiens arrivent au pays dans
les semaines suivant le tremblement de
terre
c'est un moment magique tout le monde
autour de nous recevaient leurs enfants
comme comme un cadeau et puis
le contact s'est très bien établir
rapidement ctc comme death ou des
ensembles de l'éclatement
certains parents sont fin prêts à
accueillir leurs enfants d'autres le
sont beaucoup moins
mais moi c'est ça ma spécialité c'est
des affaires comme ceux diane lavoie qui
est costumière à radio-canada a été
jumelé à sa fille une semaine seulement
avant le séisme
j'avais un travail et j'avais pas de
chambres d'enfants j'avais riez riez
riez riez
j'étais choqué
la célibataire de 52 ans a eu un autre
choc à l'aéroport au premier contact
avec sa fille de trois ans melodyne je
sais pas c'est comme dans un film au
ralenti on était très wow c'est l'fun à
souriait souriait ça a pris quatre
secondes va commencer a pu sourire j'ai
compris que ça et en dépit d'être dans
mes bras alors je lis vraiment mise à
terre posé à terre jusqu'à avant qu'à
speech elle-même puis à s'est mis à
donner des cours publics à créer pas
hurler c'est des enfants qui sont
tellement angoissé au moment où ça
arrive il y en a d'autres qui pleurent
qui ont peur
et puis bien ado qui sont complètement
dans le déni ou qui même dorment
tellement ils veulent rien savoir
la fille de diane au contraire combat le
sommeil de toutes ses forces au moment
du séisme
la petite était à l'orphelinat depuis
seulement trois mois elle était encore
en deuil de sa mère haïtienne
quand on l'a mise dans les bras d'une
nouvelle maman la première nuit je l' ai
couru dans maison était tout nu à ce que
j'ai dans les coins en boule à hurler ne
voulait pas que je la proche j'étais
complètement catastrophique alors à
parler aux sélections ont dit tu dois
faire la contention avec cette violence
le de maintenir un enfant près de soi
qui se développe qui te mords qui
dirigent des fois pendant trois heures
de temps avec toute la furie qu'elle
pouvait avoir
c'était d'une tristesse que the city
corp il faut dit il tombe des nues quand
le frère et la soeur ont été placés en
orphelinat
nike a cessé de manger se laissant
mourir de faim on a retrouvé et fait
venir la maman pour qu'elle nourrit sa
fille elle est restée comme nounou à la
crèche pendant deux ans jusqu'au départ
des enfants pour le canada quand il me
dit que j'allais partir parce que elle
avait passé tous tombés de rire mais
j'ai pleuré beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup je suis beaucoup plus
quand mon fils pleurait - les enfants
ont réagi mais beaucoup la nuit des des
réactions de l'année surtout michael
parce qu'elle avait 4 ans et demi quand
il peut arriver donc elle avait un plus
long bagages avec l d'haïti mais
autrement sa très bonne d'avoir un rêve
moi je pense à quai au look m'avoir res
labo moi je pensais qu'elle venait une
six aspects elle vaut pas bien pc très
très très malade
on a eu plus de stress post traumatique
probablement surtout des bulles le
trouble le traumatisme du départ on en a
eu plus à cause de quelque chose qui est
un nouveau facteur des enfants plus
vieux donc qu'ils étaient capables de se
souvenir d'haïti et qu'ils ont été
inquiets des gens qu'ils avaient aimé
cinq ans plus tard le traumatisme de la
rupture n'est pas oublié mais il fait
beaucoup moins mal à être un briquet
dans l'autre on est loin physique sa
source comparer un accouchement mais il
ya quelque chose on est allé dans les
tranchées ensemble et elle le sait avec
son corps que je suis toujours le même
si leurs griffes elle sait que dans
toutes les circonstances
je suis là et aujourd'hui commence avant
même période elle est aussi
spectaculaire dans le positif qu'elle a
été dans la difficulté
vraiment c'est eux et sait d'où elle
vient
telle une maturité que les enfants et
brillante mail
c'est la plus intelligente ben c'est la
plus mal c'est la plus comique c'est la
pluie